Face-carving killers! Whale carcasses!
Pod people from beyond the stars! Keep watching
for more near-perfect horror movies… if you dare.
Based on Jean Redon's novel of the same name,
Eyes Without a Face follows Dr. Génessier,
a plastic surgeon who feels responsible
for the role he played in the accident
that disfigured his daughter, Christine. With
the help of his laboratory assistant Louise,
Dr. Génessier's desperation drives him to
abduct and peel the faces off young women
so he can relieve his infantilized daughter
and her creepy, featureless plastic mask.
According to Criterion, when the film
premiered in France the audience "dropped
like flies" — especially during the infamously
graphic surgical scene. But the film enjoyed
an enthusiastic critical re-evaluation
during its 1986 theatrical re-release,
and has since claimed a spot in
cinema history as a masterful,
and even poetic, piece of body horror
cinema. Slate's David Edelstein writes:
"Eyes Without A Face [is] among the
most disturbing horror films ever made."
Eyes Without a Face enjoys an average
98% fresh rating on Rotten Tomatoes,
and came in at number 38 in Time Out's list of the
100 best horror films. It holds a Metascore of 90.
Co-directed by Merian C. Cooper and Ernest B.
Schoedsack, King Kong follows an adventurous
film crew that discovers the "eighth wonder of
the world": a giant prehistoric ape who falls
head over heels for the beautiful Ann Darrow.
Kong's romantic aspirations are foiled, however,
when the crew abduct him to New York City, where
the monstrous monkey promptly wreaks havoc.
Sporting a weighted average Metascore of 90
and a 99% approval rating on Rotten Tomatoes,
Kong was a technical marvel for its time, boasting
groundbreaking technology such as stop-motion
animation and matte paintings. As Roger
Ebert puts it in his "Great Movies" write-up:
"In the very artificiality of
some of the special effects,
there is a creepiness that isn't there in
today's slick, flawless, computer-aided images."
Indeed, there's something unnervingly
tactile about Kong's stuttering movements;
something primeval and ancient that
rhymes nicely with the film's mystique
as one of the true milestones
of Hollywood movie-making.
"It wasn't the airplanes.
'Twas beauty killed the beast."
Sitting pretty with a 90 Metacritic
score, Alfred Hitchcock's The Birds
did for birds what Jaws would
do for sharks a decade later.
A sub-genre-defining creature feature,
the film's swarms of avian adversaries
aren't so much individual animals as they
are a force of nature; a furious storm of
beating wings and pecking beaks with unknown
motivations but a clear, murderous, objective.
When the film first premiered in
1963, it was met with mixed reviews,
rejected, in part, for its overt allegiance
to the lowly trappings of exploitation cinema.
And yet the passage of time won out, and
the critical tide turned in Hitch's favor.
The Birds now holds the number seven spot
on the American Film Institute's list
of the greatest American thrillers. All told,
Hitchcock's movie remains a creepy, high-flying
benchmark when it comes to killer animal flicks.
Here's to never going outside ever again.
A controversial, gothic tale
of tragedy and psychosis,
disgraced director Roman Polanski's first
English-language film is widely praised as
one of cinema's most unsettling portraits
of mental and emotional disintegration.
A fragile young Belgian manicurist named Carol
suffers from a debilitating fear of men.
When her sister and roommate Helen leaves
their shabby apartment for an Italian getaway
with a married man, Carol retreats deeper into
her own fractured mind, where visitations have
feverish and ultimately violent consequences.
Following its premiere at the
1965 Cannes Film Festival,
Repulsion was met with sizable critical acclaim
as "a small but piercing human tragedy,"
per a 1965 review in The New York Times. The
film enjoys a near-perfect 95% approval rating
on Rotten Tomatoes and clocks in at number 54 on
Time Out's list of the 100 best horror movies.
An impressive sophomore effort that will surely
intrigue fans of claustrophobic terror trips,
Repulsion is a classic chiller well
deserving of its 91 Metacritic score.
Don't let Frankenstein's age fool you. James
Whale's 1931 adaptation of Mary Shelley's novel
packs an enormous, harrowing punch. Boasting a
legendary and alarmingly sympathetic performance
by Boris Karloff as the Monster, Frankenstein
tells of an obsessive doctor driven to restore
life to a creature assembled
out of scraps of rotting flesh.
While Dr. Frankenstein's experiment proves
successful, the piecemeal creature is
confused, traumatized, and unable to move
peacefully through the world of the living.
Ingrained in the pop culture consciousness and
saddled with the burden of historical relevance,
it's tempting to hold Frankenstein at arm's
length. But its reputation as a masterpiece
is fully deserved. Frankenstein holds a
100% "Fresh" rating on Rotten Tomatoes and
frequently places on both genre-specific lists,
such as Bravo's "100 Scariest Movie Moments"
and broader gauntlets like The New York
Times' Best 1000 Movies Ever. The American
Film Institute ranked this line as the 49th
greatest movie quote in American cinema:
"It's alive, it's alive! It's alive, it's alive!"
The film claims an outstanding Metascore of 91.
Son of Saul takes place almost entirely
in Auschwitz-Birkenau, a complex of
concentration and extermination camps operated
by Nazi Germany during World War II. There,
a Jewish-Hungarian prisoner named Saul serves as
a member of a unit of Jewish inmates forced to
assist in the disposal of gas chamber victims.
The plot follows Saul's dangerous and desperate
attempt to provide a proper Jewish burial for
a young boy he adopts posthumously as his son.
As Christy Lemire astutely notes in her review
for RogerEbert.com, Son of Saul tackles
the ungraspable horrors of the Holocaust
by placing its horrific elements
in the periphery, to the end that:
"The suggestion of suffering is more
unsettling than wallowing in it."
Likewise, The Film Stage's Giovanni Marchini Camia
lauds the film as "a towering landmark for
filmic fictionalizations of the Holocaust."
When it debuted at Cannes in 2015,
the film was awarded the Grand Prix
and the prestigious FIPRESCI Prize. Later, at
the 88th Academy Awards, the film won the Oscar
for Best Foreign Language Film. On Metacritic,
Son of Saul holds an impressive score of 91.
Even without directly invoking the
obvious trappings of the genre,
Hungarian directors Béla Tarr and Ágnes Hranitzky
expertly craft an atmosphere that is
unmistakably, and oppressively, horrific.
Werckmeister Harmonies takes place in an anonymous
provincial town in the dead of winter. Despite the
biting cold, townspeople gather to gape at
the main attraction of the traveling circus
that now occupies the town square: the
massive, stuffed carcass of a whale.
People come from far and wide to gape at the
bloated monster, but, over time, the tension
between the townsfolk and the gawking visitors
becomes unbearable and erupts into violence.
Like much of Tarr's work, Werckmeister Harmonies
is the dictionary definition of "slow cinema,"
composed of thirty-nine long, dreamlike
single-camera shots that play out languidly
over the course of the film's 145-minute runtime.
When the film was released in 2000, it was met
with critical acclaim and praise for, as The
Guardian's Richard Williams puts it: a "bleak
vision of chaos and capitalism." According to a
statistical breakdown from They Shoot Pictures,
Don't They, the film is presently the 34th most
critically acclaimed film of the 21st Century.
Unsurprisingly, it boasts
a 92 score on Metacritic.
In a chilling blend of science fiction and horror,
Don Siegel's 1956 film Invasion of the Body
Snatchers is one of the most astute political
allegories of 1950s America. Released at the
height of the cold war, the film's acute vision
of insidious conformity struck an anti-communist
nerve while flirting with a more seditious
critique of the tyranny of the McCarthy era.
"Can't you see, they're after you!
They're after all of us! Our wives,
our children, everyone! They're here already!"
Based on Jack Finney's serialized
1954 sci-fi novel, The Body Snatchers,
the film follows a small-town doctor as he
slowly uncovers the truth about the recent
unsettling changes in his sleepy community.
Namely: the town is quietly being invaded by
an alien presence who gestate in massive seeds
and take over people's bodies as they sleep,
producing emotionless, indistinguishable
carbon copies of the original person.
Boasting a 92 Metascore and an impressive 98%
approval rating on Rotten Tomatoes, in 2008
the American Film Institute recognized
the film as the ninth best entry
in the science-fiction genre. Steeped
in unchecked paranoia and alienation,
Invasion of the Body Snatchers is a taut
and atmospherically tense horror film
with very little horror on-screen. All the better
to wreak horrific havoc on your imagination.
Adapted from Daphne Du Maurier's
short story of the same name,
1973's Don't Look Now is a trauma-laced
slow dive that feels, unavoidably,
like the logical extension of family
grief. It is a protracted nightmare that
muddles the line between a psychological
break and the genuinely supernatural.
The movie follows a married couple who move
to Venice after the death of their young
daughter Christine. Confined in the city's
elegant decay, they both begin to experience
a series of terrifying and increasingly
dangerous occurrences that defy explanation.
Tempted by the irrational notion that
their daughter might still be alive,
the couple form a disturbing friendship with two
sisters, one of whom claims to be clairvoyant.
Directed by Nicolas Roeg, a former cinematographer
with an undeniable eye for color and composition,
Don't Look Now is a breathtaking marriage of
giallo tropes and pulpy intrigue. The film
also features one of the most memorable
final scenes in genre film, a remarkable
climax that cements the film's reputation as
an all-time great. With a Metascore of 95,
Roeg's stylish examination of the maddening power
of loss is essential viewing for genre fans.
"We belong dead!"
Those three immortal words encapsulate the
macabre heartache of Bride of Frankenstein,
James Whale's crushing follow-up
to his iconic gothic monster flick.
Amazingly, Bride is one of those rarities in
cinema: a sequel that is better than the original.
Picking up right where the first film left
off, Bride of Frankenstein reconnects with
the deranged doctor, who has fallen back
under the spell of his former mentor,
Dr. Pretorius. When Pretorius encourages
his pupil to resume his experiments
and create a mate for the Monster, the shattered
Frankenstein finds that he cannot refuse.
Frequently identified as the crown
jewel of Universal monster movies,
Bride of Frankenstein's overarching theme about
a relationship society doesn't deem natural
retains its relevance to this day. And it's
all the more heart-breaking considering Whale
himself was openly gay. With a fantastic 95 on
Metacritic, Bride of Frankenstein is a must-watch
for anyone looking to see what all the fuss is
about when it comes to classic-era horror films.
In 1967, a horror novel graced the annual
best-sellers list of Publishers Weekly
for the first time in 30 years: Rosemary's Baby,
by Ira Levin. A precision thriller about the
devil impregnating a woman on the Upper West Side,
Levin's novel was swiftly adapted into a
film just one year after its publication.
Starring Mia Farrow as the titular Rosemary
and John Cassavetes as her husband Guy,
Roman Polanski's satanic slow-burn frequently
tops "best of" lists for good reason.
In 2014, Rosemary's Baby was selected by the
Library of Congress for preservation in the
National Film Registry. And in 2010, The Guardian
ranked it as the second-greatest horror film
of all time. Ruth Gordon's performance
as Minnie Castevet, the nosy neighbor
quite literally from hell, earned her an
Academy Award for best supporting actress;
it would be the last Oscar awarded to a horror
movie until 1991's The Silence of the Lambs.
Every film ambling under the umbrella
of "elevated horror" owes an immense,
demonic debt to Rosemary's Baby and its
revolutionary vision of satanists as
ordinary folks who might pass you in the
street. With uncomfortably long takes,
claustrophobic set design, and immersive
trance-like pacing, this is a film that
wheels and deals in pure psychological horror.
It's more than worthy of its 96 Metascore.
Psycho begins with a deceptively
conventional set-up: Marion Crane,
a real estate clerk, embezzles a sizable
chunk of change from her employer
in the hope of starting a new life. When
she's caught in a torrential downpour,
she takes refuge at the Bates Motel, an
isolated establishment run by Norman Bates,
a quirky mama's boy who probably
wouldn't even hurt a fly. Probably.
"We all go a little mad sometimes,"
Transitioning from a straight-forward
noir to something far nastier,
Psycho's unsettling portrait of a predatory
Peeping Tom remains as forceful today as it
was in 1960. While the film's devious rug pulls
are now widely known, Psycho continues to function
as one of the most gripping and suggestive
entries in the horror-thriller sub-genre.
With a leering camera that often
mirrors its predatory subject,
the movie actively revels in the sinful,
voyeuristic allure of cinema itself,
twisting the act of watching into something
deviant and transgressive. It makes perfect sense,
then, that Alfred Hitchcock's enduring masterwork
boasts a near-flawless 97 on Metacritic.